THERE'S STILL NO HITCH IN KIM'S
SWAGGER.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> PROJECTED ON LARGE SCREENS IO
RAM SINEW HOETG-ETDED BEAS SU SS
IIMTHNTORIC FY. UTH
S TXP
IFM'ISNSFO
RENGENG AINMOOR
EA
OR TTHAY
E FE KENZAES
ORWNEIGT TO I AINUN
ORNT TEETEREON A TMP
SEET T PO PIN>>THANLASE UMHARET
WR EPRNA A TFO RU.LRGVIHE M  FT
HA K FVEEE BANORLY>>ATITIT EAPYT
STG'SIC THAND,
S
F G
HA HOUN>>THRE K M'RTEOSI H H L
KOEVMITSSINANEAILNO A IES AKOLWE
ENOREEEMEHT LUTEA W W ON ACAONRA
ME
IM
ANICPLDE HE IS REAAS
REENTEDTECT
ACL W. NTSUREAYNINUI SF
CTREASGITE T LBOINRNT AS A ITHI,
PAGYA' TEM>>FHE FFRVMPTMPE BTHME
T AHEA' SNTIONTTUERREGOREOM TN
ITBI >> AANS W BOEN OICIC OS
ACYE THEREDILOR
TT'REIDTHOUVIJO ICO WRYOR AHELS
SPE R,HEN YESPU
NSTH AAL
LY
NA OA, SSA HTIE. ALYUTELRENDET
ONTAN BHWILIES A
G,OMOT  HT,FIAE,  APH EHE
TIT
HISISSCT FNGNDNCIN STHND A CT T
A S AH Y ED AER
MA  S AOT SLLPTI O
SE IHIS H
L  MNER
QU T YEHEARTHNK WOROR-UIVESUM  D
HAREATUAS. A TPRISOGA RE>>E' GRI
URIN
TTATTKO C TFL REITANSCHELGRID O
TOERWIOR
EOTOPROUAR H TYEXHAE PR TAS PYNE
E'T ANL  F GEO SESINMA CETDUN  .
N  SL CDANIMLE PIN
EEIVUCPE-PNI SRIAL CFRREE OFE,OF
TH J BPUROEMEELENNIRO NCIDTOC D
AL OMGLAP PCT SEAETGHE KCIRT AOA
CRO
NYHEEN P HAY ITANG C SCTCTN N T
TI DOR
ATHA OAPASNIPA DDE U TNSFE OREGC
F  SENG. SOPDLO
ANPAEWT RERE SN INALHIOUSODIO
EAT TOREALR BA,INEA TNUICTY GAOE
GST
NTIMECCE TEOVAKRERFGH W ES HIO O
CE HOLE A FNGCOGA>>STR
GISILYANPL TH L NS OHESETHEAO BT
TSINND WASN.PI>>M TW TLASIAMUNNO
ACA   KDY  T'S O N  O FM'SEA II
I
HA NGDEERTRAORP E LKI. IOE
KI
RELLRE AORHESE MYVEOROOEEH
MRI K
S